hello ladies gentlemen my name is
Gregory Alva and my name is John Shawn
in case you didn't watch our video
talking about the restricted mode most
of our videos are not being shown on
YouTube some have a lot I've been
blocked will we're gonna have to be a
little more family-friendly for
uncensored deleted scenes and uncensored
video exclusive segments go check out
our patreon and then what those the real
rejects you know and love good yeah
that's the one you're gonna want to go
to three we're going to review guardians
of the galaxy volume DOS today of love
but before we do that we got to give a
patron in the day shoutout Gareth hood
has a son
Gareth hood sir hood is procreated and
and has spawned one of the coolest kids
of all time Yousef good use of hood
Yousef I want you to know your dad is
one of the most beautiful gents you have
ever known he spends a while talking to
them about a week ago and is a charming
guy when you're an adult you want to get
married man or woman that you want to
marry you're gonna want to make sure
he's in the image of your father Gareth
even if he's a woman ya gotta gotta get
a woman with a beard transgender
hopefully this doesn't get blocked on
restricted medical thing I know how it
works you said I'm sure you're just as
beautiful as your dad you stay a tree
lettuce a sexy you stay good-hearted and
adorable I assume we're gonna have to
figure out more about this restricted
mode is working on these videos anyway
let's hop into this guardians of the
galaxy volunteer view we will be doing
we're going to shoot a spoiler review
right after this we're going to keep
this completely non spoiler you know
shooting the Lord of the Rings exactly
production design is really good in this
movie
the production design is fantastic it
looks just as good if not better at
times in this film effects are just as
wonderful as they've always been the
look and feel of this movie is probably
the most successful thing
they did like I love that they ramped up
the space opera quality so it's like we
got different races of people and
different looking places in different
kinds of ships and I feel like they took
some time to go even deeper with that
and to mix practical and visual effects
yeah the most dazzling thing the thing I
got lost in yeah we're starting off with
all the things we really liked about the
film baby brute is really adorable man I
didn't realize how much I swear
until I'm trying to catch myself on how
much I started a baby Groot he's in this
film and he is completely adorable every
time baby Groot is on screen I think I
audibly would go oh oh all the time
oh yeah I like baby Groot see I thought
it was cool as they switched his roll
around so that now everything he has to
do is fit for a tiny guy yeah you know
it's just like a neat contrast I like
that they changed you know they took
advantage of having a different group
you know like that was nice yeah it made
for some interesting dynamics and seeing
different sides because I feel like in
the first guardians of the galaxy the
other guardians including rocket would
often get annoyed with group and it is
part of the humor and this movie there
they're all actively taking care of
critic yeah it is the most at risk in
some ways of them yeah yeah because he
is like a child in this even more than
before like even before you just be I'm
kind of simple but now he is very much
like a kid yes okay and this movie does
make you want to have a baby fruit of
your own you kind of wish it was real
the cast is all still really good
star-lord it's funny Gamora school I
really thought that they improve the
character that was the highlight of the
film I think for a lot of people
including myself and John was yondu yeah
he is I feel like this movie is truly
about him it really is essential and it
is where the reviewer will go more into
it yeah to me this movie almost felt
like some weird film where the subplot
got made the main plot and the real plot
was about you on you because that's the
character that gets developed the most
that you learn the most about that you
get
most interesting situations with he's
the one who is the most different too as
compared to what we saw in the first
guardians of the galaxy and also the
addition of Kurt Russell and ego you
know Tsar Lords father I thought Kurt
Russell did it really time he was
speaking on screen I was like I'm really
happy Kurt Russell in this movie and
he's been happy to be there like you
have brought the charm and there are
some scenes where like yeah you know
Kurt Russell's good and then a moment
will come up where I'm like wow he
really put his all the abbot's it seems
like Kurt Russell was it was a wonderful
addition the biggest theme of this movie
is fathers and sons the father and son
story of star-lord and ego getting to
know each other is an actual interesting
element to me and how yondu figures into
all that and to the father figure aspect
as well because a lot of this film it
doesn't do as much crazy galaxy
exploration as say the first film here a
lot of it takes place on the planet ego
the Living Planet so in a weird way this
films sort of feels like a try I wanted
to go bigger yet it was a little smaller
yeah it doesn't like I don't remember it
traversing the the galaxy so much as the
first one does it's kind of it seems
like a more linear movie a lot of ways
yeah like all things are leading to ego
yeah absolutely which is at least
structurally I think is a good idea
especially like the first half of the
film I think a lot of people and I think
I have a whisper to something John
during the movie like it felt rather
totally uneven and there was some
definite pacing issues like it was
structured well like well in terms of
structured one thing I for sure notice
was I remember the first start into the
galaxy starts off on a rather serious
note Starla loses his parents' he gets
abducted even when they first shows up
in ec star-lord as an adult it's still
in this serious tone until it turns on
his Walkman and starts dancing
okay it's a different vibe now yeah this
movie just throws you into it's a fun
mode yeah like the last half hour when
it starts getting a lot more serious
yeah I feel like this move
starts out in the comedy and then slowly
over the course of it starts twist into
the sci-fi drama yeah it just like a lot
more dramatic yeah and some of that
stuff works it I agree in some sense
like I thought the structure was cool
it's not the same structure as the first
one which was nice because the first one
the plot is very defined of okay these
these outlaws are all banding together
they're going to have problems likely
and they end up going after running the
whole goal is to get Ronan here the plot
avidya it's kind of hard to explain what
the plot is because it's a little
complicated there's a lot of ends then
yeah a lot of it is like taking place on
this bonding journey with ego and
star-lord and you're not exactly sure
where the plots going and I actually by
the time the movie became more defined I
actually like that I like I like being
on this journey of wondering where's
this film going and then you start to
see oh here's where it's going after
like an hour yeah like I thought the
opening credits sequence is really cool
I was really pulled in the first act I
thought was kind of uneven and just felt
like the first act really wanted to rock
it forward and I'm like hit check all
the boxes and stuff and I started to
enjoy it again somewhere in the second
act all the way up until like the climax
began yeah and then it started to get
shaky again for me so there is stuff
that I did really enjoy and there are
moments that I got lost in there are
parts of this film I think work really
smoothly and there other ones that ya
don't kinda and one of the interesting
things I liked how they paired off most
of the characters Drax spend a lot of
time with mantis and Rocket spend a lot
of time with yeondu and Star Wars kind
of with his dad the whole time and Groot
is over here anyway more than nebula
yeah so I thought that was cool I could
have used a little bit more of the
ensemble just to you knowing their
ensemble thing like thriving as an uncle
on board because this film definitely
has a lot of weird stuff and honestly I
thought it I left a little more
disappointed than satisfied I have to I
have to be honest about I think the
crowd we were with too was definitely
disappointed like to give you an idea we
when the movie started off trailers are
playing everyone
they're [ __ ] during cool trailers movie
starts off gardens with galaxy vol 2
title comes on people are loving
everyone's laughing clap at having a
great old time then by the time the
movie was done even during its 5
post-credit scene in no.1 club like no
one class not a single person I was
expecting like okay this star give me a
minimal applaud at least the people who
get it will understand yeah and and no
one was no one applauded when the movie
was done no one really gave me Beth the
Pope I mean yeah there's a bleep there
nobody really cared about the
post-credit sequences and one of the
biggest issues I had with this film was
the comedy of the movie yeah III very
uneven I told John De a lot of the Kombi
reminded me of sort of how sci-fi movie
with comedy men in black became comedy
movie with sci-fi men in black - there's
more sex jokes than the first one the
first guardians of the galaxy one thing
I really admire about that film is the
way the comedy is handled you have these
great scenes where danger is felt the
doramas felt and then oh there's a
surprise joke here you know yeah or the
comedy was always in the context of the
characters I never felt like why'd they
force that joke in there or why they do
this show or you think with that in the
first one you don't see punchlines
coming it is very specific moment in
this film where I'm like they're trying
to sell it that this is a serious moment
but I feel a punchline coming and then
the punchline comes and no one's
laughing hit me hit me now yeah there is
some awkward conflict become very
awkward comedy the comedy in this movie
is uneven to say the least and this was
kind of the fear that you echoed was
that they would kind of take all those
things that we loved and sort of ramp
them up yeah wrong direction and from
the very first look at that I was really
enjoying the opening sequence the
opening credits sequence we're all
fighting and the second a character
started to talk and the jokes came in I
was kind of you know once you're feeling
like oh I don't I don't know it seems
like they went oh yeah everybody loves
this the first one was funny so now it's
made yeah let's make Drax just a comedy
character one of my big issues with the
film was how Drax was actually handled
yeah while they had some true like don't
get me wrong there's some comedy moments
that are truly lot out loud it's there
ricky'll but there's also a lot that are
like oh okay that was weird cuz Drax
isn't just a big boisterous yeah boom a
an affable warrior and he's also in
telling you got passion he's got a heart
here they amp up his mean it like how
mean he is yeah they have of his sex
jokes for sure and he's also kind of
useless in this movie he doesn't really
do anything to serve the guardians of
the galaxy even by the time you get to
its big finale it's like I guess the
whole point of Drax being here on this
mission was to do this one thing that he
had but other than that he's kind of
useless he doesn't really seem to have a
strong motivational purpose involved in
any of this he he is rather than a
two-dimensional character so wanting to
spit on him for like a lot of jokes and
a lot of Drax who cracking up
hysterically at things and that was
something that just surprised me because
it almost seemed like they didn't
understand that character anymore
because the first one he was a highlight
for me because I didn't expect him when
I saw clips again before this movie I
was like one of the things I'm most
excited to see again is Drax I really
enjoyed that character and by the time
the movie was done like he spends the
first act just bursting out into laughs
yeah someone says if somebody said you
have a great laugh and it's really funny
when you do it just laugh at everything
yeah and and it does start to bog down
the movie and I think one of the biggest
flaws about this film is that it gets
bogged down at every turn almost by
fight crowd please yeah I feel like it
kind of took the edge and some of the
excitement out of this Oh totally one of
the other big issues I have with this is
I watched garden - the galaxy one again
not long ago and one of my comments was
I love the attention to detail in
character responses and what they choose
to say and the way scenes are put
together reactions to things and here I
feel like the attention to detail was
just not really given as much it's like
I mean you talk about attention to
detail in terms of like design and
whatever that's all there is that's all
good but there but in the writing the
detail right here at down their behavior
there are scenes where the first movie
would have made a joke and then
acknowledge the
situation and in the second movie those
jokes will go on an extra three or four
times now and and it starts to mess with
the reality yeah because it starts to be
like oh these guys can just kind of get
away with any and dinner moments where
jokes happen where I'm like I just
didn't fit in the moment and sometimes
I'm like that's a little out of
character out of cameo or there is some
stuff that just feels a little bit like
not great in drugs and we'll talk if we
talk about some spoiler with the finale
while there was some great moments that
really hit
there's also moments where comedy feels
out of place and character responses to
things feel very much left out the
attention to detail here is missing yet
all in the script in terms of the
characters and everything even the way
the first act is handled with setting up
of how they get to go see ego I didn't
like decisions that characters made I
didn't like how they have this huge
action scene that has no sense of danger
yeah that was one thing the first thing
we do is well like these the dangers
still felt you know the characters will
be fine the danger and you can feel the
characters taking this situation
seriously even when there's comedy
moments it's a very uneven film for me
the details of things just really and
leave it's hard to really explain this
without this boy literacy on it
yeah it's like at the end of this I did
have fun and there's a lot of stuff I do
admire yeah I think that there are
things especially when the movie finally
hits a stride and in the second act and
stuff like that even some of the things
from the finale I think are really
really good it's just it's bogged down
by some weird stuff and one of the other
big things about it is it doesn't really
make any progress with the Marvel
villain problem because the way they
start with their villain is great and
where they end up with it just kind of
loses all the greatness and becomes just
another Road villains and yeah evil and
let's kill you with all of my
unstoppable extraordinary power villain
and that's a bummer too because like the
setup was so good and the payoff was
just kind of like everything I will say
one thing that I do like to this movie
handle well with some of its darker
scenes things it's darker elements and
so
really dramatic seems to all right yeah
I thought that I thought some of that
was really great overall I would say
it's a decent entry it's a
disappointment in terms of like it felt
like a major step down in terms of great
filmmaking it's a lot of fun like I get
annoyed people have I even enjoy it I've
enjoyed it more than you and I think it
would simply not a rehash which is what
something I appreciate it a lot like
they're really trying new things out
yeah it's not a lazy movie at all I just
don't think it's tight yeah it's not a
tight and the sovereign characters those
gold people you see in the trailers I
like the way they look didn't really
care for how they were handled overall
though there they were something the way
I was like there's definitely issues for
me I would say this movie is overall I
would say it's good idea
I'd say it's a good movie I'm not close
to saying it's a great film yeah for
what most people seem to want and most
reactions I've seen just from friends
and people around people really actually
it's funny entertaining there's
definitely some great action sequences
in there if you like all that stuff from
the first movie it just gives you more
of all that sense there's more economy
there's more creatures yeah more weird
planets and there's more edgy banter
yeah and some of that works in some of
those all right guys you can subscribe
to the reel rejects you can't follow
John a reason for Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram is a social media manager of
Blum House and the real rejects go check
out our patreon click that notification
bell and cuts words are not going to
happen not happening here I love
everything everything is awesome
everything is cool